this word is orbital it is about how
electrons orbit around the nucleus in an
atom now we used to think
Rutherford's time that the electron went
ground like the earth goes around the
Sun but in fact you can't treat it like
that because the electron is all over
the place behaves like a wave you can't
tell exactly where it is but you can
tell the approximate volume that it
occupies and the volume has a really
funny shape and they're different shapes
that are important for different atoms
in fact it's these different shapes that
give the periodic table its whole
structure the simplest shape is called
an S orbital sphere then there are three
orbitals called P orbitals which look
like this which have two blobs with a
nucleus in the middle one pointing
upwards once pointing towards you
and the third one if I don't drop it
pointing out of the door the third sort
are called D orbitals which have four
blobs which can point in three different
directions so we have three like this
and then we have two more and running
out of hands one which looks like one
which looks like this and the final one
looks a bit strange
called DZ squared looks like a disk
threaded onto a dumbbell there is a four
thought called F orbitals there seven of
them too complicated for me to afford
the models and with these orbitals you
can explain the whole structure of the
periodic table s and P orbitals for the
main group n elements hydrogen chlorine
and so on D orbitals for the transition
metals iron copper nickel and the F
orbitals for the two rows at the bottom
the rare earths and the actinides this
is short very simplified but the idea of
orbitals is absolutely
kitu chemistry you can explain how atoms
bond together to make molecules and
chemists use orbitals every day
Mendeleev who devised the structure of
the periodic table didn't know about
electrons hadn't been invented
they was discovered just before he died
we never believed they were important
but we now know it's the key to the
whole periodic table